you
[Music]
I'm really delighted this afternoon to
be able to introduce one of the MS Rai
distinguished lecturers in David boy
who's from the University of Columbia
University he is in the professor in
statistics computer science and in the
Institute for data science
David and before that he was at yes
Princeton CMU and got his PhD with Mike
Jordan at at Berkeley about 15 years ago
so a youngster by my standards and he's
amazingly famous for his work in topic
modeling both the theory and the
practice of it as well as more generally
in Bayesian machine learning
David is as I said very well known he
has awards he's a fellow of the ACM a
fellow of the IMS the Institute for
mathematical statistics he's won the ACM
prize in computing and he has several
test of time Awards in both machine
learning and information retrieval and
other conferences the breadth of his
influence is also seen I think in his
citations he's somebody who has almost
70,000 citations
27,000 of them for one paper that I will
mention in in in passing that's almost
seven citations per workday since it was
published in 2004 and it's the work
which is how I got to know him on latent
DeRusha lay allocation so he took some
of the work that I had done earlier and
others on latent semantic indexing work
that Thomas Hoffman and christos
papadimitriou had done on generative
models probabilistic models for in word
embeddings and really generalized that
on a number of dimensions put it on
sound probabilistic foundations and as
you can see that paper has had
tremendous influence in the in both
statistics and computer science
community over the years his co-authors
on that paper were and ruing and Michael
Jordan also very well known
researchers in computer science
he's long had a great relationship with
Microsoft research I think you as a
graduate student he was supported by an
MS our fellowship he did an internship
here with David Hackerman and who was
your office mate was held MA and we've
remained close friends with David and
his students you know through the years
today and in he's done over the years
more than the LDA paper he's done really
foundational work on approximate
inference he's done a lot of work
adapting topic models to include
structure hierarchical structure
temporal structure and really applied
these ideas to lots of real-world
problems whether it's looking at a
hundred years of papers and in science
or the New York Times or looking at
electronic medical records and I think
that back and forth between theory and
practice of taking a problem that grabs
you and then trying to understand it and
improve the models to to accommodate it
or one of the measures of his success in
in my mind today he's since he's gone to
Columbia he's shifted gears a little bit
and has been doing a lot of work on
causal reasoning and today what he's
going to do is is tell us about some of
that work and the the basic idea is to
think about how we can do causal
imprints from observational data when we
haven't done nicely control these
experiments and there's as the title of
the talk suggests there are some some
advantages to be found when you have
multiple causal variables and that they
have some structural relationship
amongst each other and so he's gonna
leverage some of that in his talk so
without further ado I'll bring on David
to give us an awesome talk
thanks sue for that wonderful
introduction it's great to be here at
MSR like so you said I've been coming
here since I was a graduate student in
the in 2000 I think I came for the first
time and I'm from Colombia and I'm gonna
talk about the blessings of multiple
causes so I wanted to start by just
telling you a little bit about what my
group works on at Columbia okay so but I
didn't even need to say this we have
complicated data we want to make sense
of it okay well this is true in many
many settings it might be that we have a
big collection of text documents like
for LSA or Lda and we want to understand
what's in the text documents maybe were
economist Trish ins we have a big data
set about people buying food at the
supermarket we want understand how
people shop maybe we built a big social
network and we want to understand we
want to make sense of the people
connecting to each other and sending
messages to each other or maybe we're
physicists and we want to understand
something about the universe from our
complicated data about the universe so
let's unpack these I this statement a
little bit what is complicated data well
traditionally that might mean it's just
big we have many many data points or
it's wide we have many many dimensions
many things that we measure about those
data points but data can be complicated
especially the kind of data you look at
here in other ways like we might have
elaborate structures and relationships
like in text data where there's where
there's syntactic structure and semantic
structure or we might have data and
especially common now where we have
different interconnected types of data
like we might have images links texts
cliques if we have search engine logs or
if we have a big social network or
something like that so these are all
ways that data is complicated it's more
complicated than it was and you know
when your grandparents are analyzing
data so what does it mean to make sense
of data well that also has several
meanings again the meaning we might
first think of is we want to make
predictions about the future okay I
ingest the query log for this much time
and I want to know what's the query log
and I look like tomorrow okay but there
are other ways of making sense of data
too we might want to identify
interpretable patterns what types of
queries are being sent or we might want
to do science confirm elaborate and form
cause
theories in other words I want to
understand something about how people
search for things based on the query
logs and I see these as three almost
three different levels of making sense
of data so what we work on in my lab is
probabilistic machine learning this is
about developing machine learning
methods that connect our domain
knowledge and theories about these
different domains to the data that we
want to analyze within them and the idea
is that probabilistic machine learning
is a methodology for articulating
assumptions and then for computing with
those assumptions basically say what we
want to say about how we think the
universe is formed and then compute
under those assumptions about the data
that we see there and our goal in my lab
is to make this this way of doing
machine learning expressive so that we
can express many different kinds of
assumptions about data scaleable so we
can handle the kinds of massive data
sets that we encounter today and easy to
develop so that we can easily program
these types of machine learning
solutions just to be clear it's not that
different from applied Bayesian
statistics which are statistical methods
that connect domain knowledge to data
okay so some of the work that we've done
in my group recently here's a picture of
communities discovered in a big 3.7
million node Network so finding
overlapping communities in a big network
this is some analysis of fMRI data where
we had a big data set of fMRI
measurements people looking at different
things under the fMRI machine and we
want to know which parts of the brain
are active when they're looking at
different things here's a topic model
like what su mentioned this one's fit to
1.8 million articles from the New York
Times when we were first working on this
we analyzed 5,000 articles now we can
analyze 1.8 million articles just on a
laptop and here this is a topic model
where each each little node here is a
collection of words associated under a
single theme discovered by the algorithm
this is a population genetics analysis
of a big data set of of people's genes
that tries to capture ancestral
structure which which which ancestries
mix to form the people in the data set
and more recently we've been working
with economy Tricia's this is a fancy
discrete choice and now assistent
analysis
how people purchase things of 5.7
million supermarket purchases and this
picture was a big deal to the Economist
it shows us that crackers and cheese go
together okay so all those pictures are
from recent applied work in our lab and
they all follow in some sense this
pipeline I call it the probabilistic
pipeline where we start with our
knowledge about the world and a question
we want to answer we use it to make
assumptions in the form of a probability
model that has hidden and observed
variables we then square our modeling
assumptions and our data to discover
patterns to infer the hidden variables
given the observations and finally we
use those discovered patterns to form
predictions to explore to do whatever it
is we're gonna do with the data set and
I like this picture you might think it's
a little vacuous but I like this picture
because it separates these activities of
articulating our theories and
assumptions computing about them and
then using the results of that
computation and this makes it easy or
easier to collaborate with domain
experts on solving machine learning
problems so what I want to we work on
really every aspect of this of this
picture I have other talks about making
assumptions or discovering patterns but
what I want to talk about today is the
last box what do we do with those
discovered patterns and in particular I
want to talk about as sue mentioned how
can we understand the world through
observational data right so causal
inference from observational data this
is important if you sit down with a
domain expert and start talking about
her data you learn that what almost
everybody wants to do is some kind of
causal inference really understand how
the world works from their data and this
is true in any field and I want to talk
about how to use probabilistic machine
learning to do this kind of causal
inference I should mention this is all
joint work with my student Eugene Wang
anything you like about this work is you
Sheen's contribution whatever you don't
like about the work was my injected
variance to this
so I'm gonna start with this idea called
the D confounder okay so we've been
talking about lots of important problems
but let's talk about a silly not
important problem which is the problem
of determining how much money and actor
is worth okay so imagine you're a
big-shot movie producer and you have a
bunch of data about movies who is in the
movie and how much money the movie made
and your goal is to understand the
causal effect of putting an actor in the
movie okay this is causal because it's a
question about an intervention how much
money will the movie make if I put if I
make a movie with a particular cast okay
so here's the data this is real data and
you can see each row it's a movie
there's avatar and this is who's in the
movie and then at the end the last
column is how much money the movie made
and the naive solution to solving this
problem would be to fit a regression
right or even more naively use deep
learning okay and what we would do is
the you know when you when you use deep
learning you just you just throw the
actors in as features who's in what
movie is a feature and then the revenue
is the response and you build a little
neural network that takes in a cast and
spits out a response this estimates the
revenue as a function of which actors
are cast okay but standard machine
learning doesn't provide causal
inferences in the and the if you're new
to causal inference it's all about the
tense of the verb that you use whether
an actor was cast in a movie is
different from casting an actor if you
go to the movies and Sue is in the movie
that's different from you saying I'm
gonna make a movie and I'm gonna put sue
in the movie okay causal inference is
about prediction under intervention what
will the movie make if I put sue in the
movie what's the problem with causal
inference from observational data its
summarized well by this picture so I
have some bullets about this picture if
you don't know it so this is a picture
from the movie From Russia With Love
it's a James Bond movie from the 60s and
as far as causal inference is concerned
here's what you should know about James
Bond movies
James Bond movies are about James Bond a
British spy ok this is James Bond here
is played by Sean Connery who by the way
is a very good actor but James Bond
movies it's a series and they always
cast the same group of characters ok
there's James Bond but there's other
people too there's the person playing em
that's the person in charge of the
British Secret Service there's the
person playing Q he's the guy that gives
James Bond his gadgets like the pen that
makes people faint and stuff and there's
also Miss Moneypenny who's not pictured
here
she's M secretary okay so they're all in
all the James Bond movies and forth then
I'll go to 3rd James Bond movies always
do well at the box office they make a
lot of money whenever you make a change
mob movie it'll make a lot of money and
also M Q and Miss Moneypenny they only
appear in James Bond movies okay those
are the only movies they're in Sean
Connery's and other movies too and if
you know more about James Bond then I
hope then just pretend there's only one
James Bond okay pretend that only Sean
Connery is James Bond you might want to
pretend that anyway okay so now so
what's the problem with James Bond
movies well imagine now running a simple
regression on that data and what you'll
see
because MQ and Miss Moneypenny are only
in James Bond movies that you're going
to learn that they're worth a lot of
money right if I put whoever plays em in
my movie it's gonna make a lot of money
because all the movies that M appeared
in make a lot of money what's that she
said that's not a bad assumption with
the previous M she knows too much about
James Bond movies for this to be a
useful education but but but that's the
idea right that that that a naive
regression is going to say that M is
worth a lot of money because whenever M
is in a movie it makes a lot of money
but of course we know that's not true
right and so in the world of causal
inference the deal is that James Bond
this is what's called an unobserved
confounder a confounder is a variable
I've pictured it here that affects both
the causes who is in the movie and the
effect
and confounders bias passive machine
learning when it's used to form a
prediction about an intervention okay
some actors are overestimated like m and
Q and others are underestimated like
Sean Connery maybe that's the idea and
unobserved confounders are everywhere if
you want to make causal inferences about
all kinds of domains like this there are
going to be some unobserved confounders
like James Bond Ness lurking in your
data set and this is the key challenge
to causal inference from observational
data okay so what's the classical
solution to this problem of unobserved
confounders well it's to observe them so
first you you know you want to do a
causal inference so first you think
about what confounders might be in your
data that's the first step then you
measure those confounders okay this is a
test-tube it's somebody measuring
confounders then you add the confounders
to your data set and you estimate the
causal effects using the beautiful
theory of causal inference okay so but
this classical approach to causal
inference requires that we find and
measure all the confounders a sufficient
set of confounders to make causal
inference possible but whether or not
we've included a sufficient number of
confounders is famously untestable okay
and so this classical solution rests on
hope and makes us worry that's why I
drew this person with worried eyebrows
because they're worried that they're
missing some confounders but the point
of this talk is that this problem is not
classical instead of a typical causal
inference problem does advil help with
headaches
we have many possible causes one per
actor we call this a multiple causal
inference and the idea behind this work
is that when you have multiple causes
this they help us construct a variable
that contains some of the unobserved
confounders okay that's the whole point
of this talk that when we have this type
of setting we can construct a variable
that contains some of the unobserved
confounders and in fact it's a variable
that's constructed in all of these types
of latent variable models that I showed
you in the beginning when I was talking
about the work in my group
okay so here's the idea we call it the D
confounder first we're gonna model the
assigned causes okay so here at a are
the actors who's in what movie we're
gonna build a little probability model
of who's in the movie like a matrix
factorization then we're gonna use that
model to estimate what we call a
substitute confounder it's the local
latent variable for the for each movie
and then we're gonna use that substitute
confounder as though it were a real
confounder and correct for it to perform
causal inference okay so that's the idea
I'm gonna explain it in detail later
okay so in there in words find fit and
check a factor model of the assigned
causes use that model to form a
substitute confounder and then use the
substitute confounders downstream in a
causal model of the outcome that you
care about okay for those of you
familiar with these ideas for example
you might find fit and check a
probabilistic matrix factorization of
movie casts okay so treat the movie cast
is a big matrix and factorize that
matrix just the movie casts then use
that model to infer a per movie variable
in the matrix factorization and then use
that per movie variable as though it
were an unobserved confounder now
observed and correct the regression from
casts earnings with it okay and it works
so the value of m and q go down and the
value of sean connery goes up when we do
this equally superfluously we can look
at who gets better and who gets worse or
who is valued more and who is valued
less when we correct for confounding in
this movie example we find that Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Robert De Niro and
Brad Pitt are overestimated their value
goes down when we correct for
confounding Antonio Banderas and Kate
Blanchette and Nic Cage and oh and
Wilson are underestimated their value
goes up when we correct for confounding
and Christopher Walken and Susan
Sarandon and Ben Affleck and Stanley
Tucci and Willem Dafoe
I always remember Willem Dafoe as my
wife has a crush on
Defoe they are the most corrected actors
they're the ones that go up the most
okay so once I gave this talk and there
was like a reporter in the audience and
later she asked me you know were those
results credible and they're not these
are not credible results okay but they
show you that we get different estimates
when we correct for deep for confounding
in this way and I'll show you some real
simulations at the end of the talk so
why does this work the intuition is that
multi cause confounders confounders like
james bond nests that effect multiple of
the actors as well as the revenue
induced dependencies among the causes
appearing in the data right so James
Bond Ness induces a dependency between
whoever plays em and whoever plays Q and
that dependence is encoded in the data
while we can't observe James Bond s we
can see that M and Q seem to be could
connected to each other and so we can
capture it with a factor model the
assumption that we make rather than no
unobserved confounders is that there no
unobserved single cause confounders in
particular there's no variable lurking
in my data that only affects whether
Sean Connery's in the movie and the
revenue that would be an unobserved
single cause confounder but what we
claim is that no unobserved single cause
confounders is weaker than no unobserved
confounders so this is causal inference
with weaker assumptions then classically
is required yeah I can imagine a world
where M really was the reason that James
Bond movies were successful and yet the
data is showing that it's Sean Connery
who's responsible so what what is
intuitively what is it that's making
that distinction so right you're saying
you can imagine a world where M only
appears in the James Bond movies but
he's but he is that you see it for M
yeah
if that's the case then when but Sean
Connery still appears in all the usual
movies any else appears in that if that
were the case then those movies wouldn't
do as well the other Sean Connery movies
with money yeah also get the benefit
just being alongside em yeah so right so
right so first then Sean Connery's
movies won't make as much money if that
were the case but to be clear let's say
M is really the star but M only ever
appears with Q and Miss Moneypenny this
method cannot tell the difference no no
method could tell the difference between
M being the star or Q being the star or
Miss Moneypenny being the star because
they are perfectly dependent profits an
effect of the movie it's not measurable
instantaneously I'm gonna say the movie
that was released 10 years ago this is
how much money today these yesterday
didn't make us much money right so I
think this is revenue after so many
months and that somehow corrected for
the occasion in time machine I believe
did that too the response had she not
it's my fault okay now the the actor
example of course is not the only
multiple causal inference this is kind
of everywhere so how do jeans effect the
trait the causes are genetic variation
which we might measure you know on a
hundred thousand locations in the genome
the effect is the trade itself and the
confounder is ancestry each person's
ancestry induces a correlation in
multiple genes just like james bond this
induces the correlation among multiple
actors and this can confound our
estimate of the of the effect of each
gene on the trait okay in sports the
causes might be who is in the game the
effect is the points scored in the game
you want to know the value of a player
but the confounder is that the coach
might use multiple players together in
economics the causes might be the prices
of each item for sale that's what you're
interested in the causal effect of the
price of peanut butter
the effect is how much money is spent by
consumers if I
the price of peanut butter how's that
going to change the economy and the
confounder are things like holidays and
seasonality which affect the prices and
demand for multiple items okay so these
unobserved confounders but multiple
causal inference problems are all over
the place
okay so that's idea here are some of the
details so our observed data set D is a
collection a 1 Y 1 2 a n yn each a is a
collection of causes so here it's like a
bunch of binary variables for whether or
not each act which actors in this movie
the right movie the outcome is why I and
our goal is again to do causal inference
to look at the expectation of the
revenue and this is the pearls dude
notation in the world where I intervene
and I set the cast equal to a ok or I
might look for some contrast of you know
here's a cast and I change the cast by
one person for example okay so you read
this as the expectation of Y in the
model where I intervene on a now the
problem of causal inference is that if
there are unobserved confounders then
the interventional expectation does not
equal the conditional expectation the
conditional expectation I can get from
my data but the interventional
expectation is not the thing I can get
from my data okay again we're gonna find
fit and check a factor model of movie
casts use it to form substitute
confounders and then use those
substitute confounders downstream in a
causal model so let's go through each of
those steps when I say probabilistic
factor model I mean a model that has the
following form for each cause there's
some representation beta J that comes
from a prior for each individual each
movie for example there are some
representations Zi that comes from a
prior and then whether or not actor J is
in movie I comes from some distribution
that depends on the movie representation
and the actor representation okay this
is what we mean by a factor model and it
turns out if you squint at a lot of the
models that you might learn about in a
machine learning course mixture models
matrix factorization deep generative
models topic models etc models that you
would find by opening these books to a
random page
age they are factor models okay so you
can kind of look at all of these things
as types of factor models in this sense
okay so here's a factor model I like
it's called poisson factorization just
as an example and what it says as a
generative model is that there's a K
vector of non-negative values beta for
each actor there's a K vector of
non-negative values Z for each movie and
then whether or not actor I appears in
movie J comes from a plus on or a
truncated plus on whose rate is the
inner product of those two
representations okay this is like a
Bayesian version of non-negative matrix
factorization okay I'm called Poisson
factorization it's a nice model because
it provides a generative model of these
assigned causes and it can be fit to
large data sets with variational methods
okay so in the first step what we do is
we fit one of these factor models to
just the assigned causes okay so to be
clear we throw away the outcome in this
in this step consider the data set of
casts approximate the posterior
distribution of the per movie
representation and the per actor
representation using something like
variational inference or whatever you
want and that's the first step of the D
confounder again we only model the
actors the outcome is not involved okay
so here's here's an example here are
different movies
well yeah here are different movies and
here's an example of the per movie
representation that we get in this way
okay and we're not going to try to
interpret it they sort of are
interpretable but the point is that we
get these per movie representation okay
so in the second step of the D
confounder what we're going to do is
estimate the local latent variable Zi
and Zi hat is going to be the posterior
expectation of the eighth movies
representation given its cast and our
representation of the actors okay and
that's what we've Illustrated here these
are some zi hats for different movies
when then gonna check how well Zi Hat
captures the distribution of actors okay
how well does the representation of
unforgiven capture the actual cast of
unforgiven
and I don't have details in this talk
but there's some extra slides at the end
we can use some kind of predictive check
on actors or you can just gate take held
out data or whatever you want to test
the check the fidelity of Z I hat okay
so those are the first two steps fit one
of these factor models and then estimate
the local latent variable and see how
well it captures your distribution of
data now to be clear I use Poisson
factorization just as an example but you
can use any factor model okay so
probabilistic PCA plus on factorization
mixture models deep exponential families
these are all examples of probabilistic
factor models and each one performs
differently in terms of measuring how
well it captures the distribution of
actors okay and you make a little table
like this to decide which factor model
fits best yeah you mean by captures that
so you're using Z
yeah no I'm using Z to predict eggs I'm
using Z to predict who is in the movie
okay yep so just to make it really clear
take your casts fit the model say take
your casts for each movie hold out two
or three actors fit your model to the
remaining actors and then ask how well
did the the fitted model capture the
held out actors that's a check of how
well I'm capturing the population
distribution of actors using my fitted
Z's yeah okay and and so this predictive
check produces a predictive score it's
all very mysterious on this slide but
the point of this is that look these
three models loosely pass the check this
mixture model failed the mixture model
was not expressive enough to capture the
distribution of actors now the idea is
that the estimated local variables if
they pass that check our substitute
confounders they are the latent
attributes of movie casts and they
capture these multi cause confounders
that we talked about in the first part
of the talk so the next step is to form
an Augmented data set where I have the
cast the revenue and this Z hat notice I
didn't go in measure
anything like James Bond Nisour sequels
or whatever it is the I think might be
compounding my estimates rather I just
used Z hat which passed some kind of
predictive check okay so now here's my
augment to data set with the Z hats next
to the cast's next to the revenue and
then finally I'm going to use the
substitute confounder in a causal
inference for example what that means is
that I'm going to fit some kind of model
of my revenue given the cast and my
substitute confounder okay this is the
simplest one it's just a regression it
doesn't work the best where it just says
there's a coefficient for the cast and a
coefficient for the substitute
confounder and I fit this regression to
this data finally this is the only part
I won't explain use some kind of causal
inference then to use the results of
that regression to estimate the
interventional expectation okay so this
for example is called the G formula and
loosely it is how to correct for
confounding if you had observed the
confounders okay it's looking at a
weighted average of expected revenues
given substitute confounders and casts
okay so those are the three steps find
fit and check a factor model of movie
casts use it to form substitute
confounders and then use the substitute
confounder downstream in a causal
inference and the steps you know from
the modeling perspective are choosing a
factor model and choosing what we call
an outcome model a way to capture
revenue given substitute confounding in
cast good question so how do we choose
the cardinality of Z I have an answer
and then I really don't know the answer
what we do is we choose K the
cardinality of Z to be big enough to
pass the predictive check but no bigger
and the reason is that if it's bigger
then it's going to start capturing stuff
about the actors that we need to
estimate the downstream causal effects
and this has to do with like the
bias-variance tradeoff of this procedure
which we don't totally understand right
when if you over here overfitting has
bad consequences because if you over fit
you lose a lot of the information that
you need to estimate the downstream
causal effects okay this is how I got
this credible picture okay so yeah what
is the role of beta in the model this is
just marginalized value we just take a
point estimate of beta we look at the
Bayes estimate the expectation of beta
given the data it can be you can do
whatever you want with beta what's
really important is Z so you need beta
to help define how Z defines a
distribution of actors but it can be a
point estimate or it can be a whatever
you want okay so I've kind of asserted
for you twice that this algorithm is a
good algorithm and the paper tells you
why it works but I want to kind of give
you a hint at what the theory is around
this this procedure okay and so the
theory says the following suppose we fit
a good factor model of the assigned
causes and by good I mean one that
captures the distribution of actors then
it's local latent variables Z will
capture multi cause confounders the main
assumption is that there are no single
cause confounders and
stopping short of a foolproof there's a
graphical model argument that basically
gives you all the intuition about about
why this is true
okay so here's a little graphical model
and here I have the variables AI 1 2 AI
m eat for each actor whether or not he
or she is in the movie now if I find a
good factor model then that means that
the Joint Distribution of the actors is
described by this picture and in this
picture because you know about graphical
models because they were practically
invented here the conditional
distribution it sorry the the joint
distribution of the actors are
conditionally independent given the
substitute confounder and beta right
that's what this picture tells us beta
is lurking in the background here just
focus on the substitute confounder this
if if their joint is described by this
picture then they are conditionally
independent given the latent variable
now let's add the outcome here's the
outcome y:i here is a multi cause
confounder w okay now why is it a multi
cause confounder well it is correlated
to the outcome and it's also correlated
to several causes the theory says that W
cannot exist if we have described the
Joint Distribution with this latent
variable model because if W did exist
then a I 1 - a I M would not be
conditionally independent given Z and
you can see that just by looking at this
back to our path from A to W right even
if I condition on Z AI 1 is going to be
dependent on a I am here make sense and
so that's a contradiction so W can't
exist there can't be whatever
information is in W that we're assuming
is there that information is also going
to be in Z and this is all made more
formal in the paper now as for the
assumption that there's no single cause
confounder well you can see that that
does not break this conditional into
his assumption right if si is lurking in
the background and it affects whether
Sean Connery's in the movie and the
revenue si can still exist because the
the fact that si is there does not break
the conditional independence that given
Z these a what these A's are independent
okay so the theorem is that if the
population distribution of causes can be
written as a factor model then the the
local latent variable blocks the
backdoor path between the causes and the
effect which means we can use it to
correct for confounding this implies
that I can write down the interventional
expectation using backdoor adjustment
it's a little more complicated than this
but if you're interested in how it's
more complicated ask me at the end and I
have some slides at the end about how
it's a little bit more complicated yeah
intuitively then if I have a marketing
cost confounder where the number of
things is actually affecting is this
becoming larger and larger does my
gaiter requirement actually become worse
because I have to intuitively estimate
like higher moments of the data sorry if
you have a multi cost confounder so
sadder but more and more causes yes
suppose I have something that only
affects like two actors versus something
that always join key effects like a
couple of hundred actors yeah
how does my here right but I mean yeah I
don't know how to think about that and
I'll tell you why
on the one hand if I have a multi cause
confounder that only affects a couple of
the causes then in the causal inference
part of my of my algorithm it's not
adding too much confounding there
probably won't be that much confounding
bias due to that multi cause confounder
so that should make me feel good about a
cop multi cause confounder that only has
that the only effects couple however
that multi cause confounder is going to
be harder to capture with the factor
model whereas a multi cause confounder
like you described that affects many
many many actors let's say James Bond
movies contain thousands of people in
them then that one's going to be easy to
capture from the data so so these these
are at odds with each
yeah it's an interesting question okay
so that's a little bit about why it
works
we ran many simulations and studies
here's a collage that I made have the
simulations and studies that we ran good
it's let it have its effect on you okay
so one of the simulations is around G
wasps so g wasps genome-wide Association
studies is a problem of multiple causal
inference and the question we want to
answer there is how is genetic variation
causally connected to a trait and the
problem and and so in G wasps for every
individual we measure a trait like their
height and then many many measurements
of their genomes snips single nucleotide
polymorphisms now in jiwa studies
multiple cause confounding is a problem
non-causal snips non-causal variation
could be highly correlated to causal
variation because of latent ancestry and
this Mis estimates causal effects right
M is overestimated and Sean Connery is
underestimated so we ran a simulation
here's our data first we generate
genetic variation where each individual
belongs to some latent group CI some
latent ancestral group okay so we made a
hundred thousand snips for each person
and their values are one zero or two and
we generated this from some kind of
realistic model of genetic variation
that included this latent ancestry then
we modeled the outcome like height and
we modelled it from a little regression
where each snip has some coefficient
beta J the beta J's are sparse only some
of the snips are causal then there's an
intercept term that it uses the latent
ancestry and then there is a noise term
and the noise term also depends on the
latent ancestry in terms of its variance
okay
so notice that the latent ancestry or
the observed ancestry in the simulation
is a confounder right it affects both
the snips and the outcome that we care
about
okay so there's confounding here built
into this data now we're going to do the
D confounder thing we fit many factor
models and I want to emphasize that none
of them is the true model okay so none
of them is the model that generated the
snips but they're all factor models
probabilistic factor models and each of
them performs differently in terms of
how well they capture the population
distribution of the causes okay it's not
what this talk is about but I should add
that we did all of this with a
probabilistic programming system okay so
when you want to fit many many
probability models it's not just that
we're gonna run one model and then write
a paper about it
but we're gonna fit many models we use
probabilistic programming to help us do
inference easily on many models okay so
we fit many factor models then we fit
outcome models with no control so
ignoring that there might be confounders
controlling for the confounders where we
magically observe the confounders that
we don't really get to observe and then
using each of these factor models to
form a substitute confounder okay I also
want to emphasize each of these as a
factor model has some notion of a local
variable but they're all different right
so the deep exponential family for
example is like a deep learning type
model it's got a multi-layered local
latent variable plus on factorization
has a non-negative local latent variable
probabilistic PCA has a real valued
local latent variable but the idea
behind the method is that each of those
local variables could potentially
capture the unobserved confounding okay
and so we used each of them to give us a
substitute confounder and here we see
the mean squared error between our
estimates of the coefficients beta and
the truth for the causal snips and what
you can see is the following story if we
don't control for confounding there is
we're far away from the truth if we
control for confounding we're quite a
bit closer but these d confounded
estimates also get closer even though we
don't get to observe the
and moreover when the predictive check
fails the estimate of the of the causal
coefficient also fails and when the
predictive check did best the estimate
of the causal coefficient also did best
okay so this is suggesting that the
method it works well in fact in the
world of genome-wide Association studies
this technique of reducing the dimension
of the snips and then using that reduced
dimension to correct for downstream
modeling of the outcome is done all the
time although the perspective that
what's really happening is that it's
capturing unobserved confounding because
of this kind of theory is is not there
and the idea of posterior predictive
checks to understand which confounders
are best
so one could take any of these methods
so you could square them off against
each other which is essentially what we
did here to understand which ones work
best with Jie wasps data okay so that's
my talk how can we understand the world
through observation it's important
everywhere and I showed you how to use
probabilistic machine learning to help
do causal inference from observational
data again find fit and check the factor
model of assigned causes use it to form
substitute confounders for each
individual and then use those substitute
confounders downstream in a causal model
if we find a good factor model of the
assigned causes then its local latent
variable will contain multi cause
confounders that's our theorem but of
course there are assumptions this uses
probabilistic machine learning I didn't
mention this but we can this doesn't
require any kind of exact inference okay
so Poisson factorization we can't do
exact inference but that doesn't matter
because all we're doing is checking that
those Z's capture the distribution of
the of the other causes and this
requires weaker assumptions in classical
causal infants okay so if you're
interested in reading more there's our
paper there's some other readings about
multiple causality and we're doing a lot
of current research on multiple
causality including a lot of
applications to some things that you
care about here like medicine
recommendation systems and fairness
thanks very much yeah sim side there's
another dimension which is like whether
you thinking some song in here yeah so
yeah repeat the question so the question
was we I talked about the bias-variance
tradeoff around the number of latent
factors in the in the factor model but
you're saying that there's also another
decision to make about the outcome model
is it linear as a nonlinear and that's
true so the outcome model that works
best for us really is a nonlinear one
it's one where you it's a it's linear
but it's linear in a nonlinear function
of the substitute confounder where you
we you form what we call the
reconstructed causes these are the the a
hat it's the expectation of a given Z
hat it's the it's the cast you think you
would get if Z hat were the substitute
confounder and when a hat is brought
into the outcome model say a regression
we only tried regressions then that's a
nonlinear function but that performs
much better than this linear model
taking Z hat directly but again
understanding the bias-variance tradeoff
is something that's on our list like
with what you suggest that would incur
even more variance but might be more
accurate yeah yeah
my questions about the fairness
application of this kind of an approach
in the sense that imagine there's a
minority class there are historical
other kind of reasons and that's I think
of confounding factors that could be
explained by such a model explaining it
doesn't doesn't really change the fact
that the recommendation engine may never
recommend somebody from that minority
population because there is no positive
evidence to show that those people could
succeed at a given job because they were
never given that opportunity yeah what
are your talks about these kind of
approaches and the intervention and
whether they are suspecting to have the
right intervention that's a good
question so um you know our work in
fairness is so there's kind of the
reason it connects to the D compounder
is the following our work in fairness is
around setting up a causal model of the
attributes both the sensitive and non
sensitive attributes including things
like a sensitive attribute having an
effect on a non sensitive attribute
because of some kind of unfair situation
in society and then using that model to
then form machine learning predictors
that can satisfy various causal metrics
for fairness and so that's that's our
work comparing us but it all ours and
other work in fairness often presupposes
that you have a good causal model and
unconfoundedness with those kinds of
data sets to produce a D confounded
causal model of the sensitive and non
sensitive attributes and then use them
downstream in some way to correct for
the for the for example for the
disparate effect that using a test to do
admissions for example might have on a
on a on a sensitive on a protected group
that said you brought up an interesting
situation where there's zero overlap
where if there really was a situation
where nobody was ever so you know the
the the methods that we developed would
do things like up wait the information
when someone
was unlikely to get in got in and then
did well for example but when there's no
overlap I don't think there is a
mathematical solution to that yeah yeah
so what do you think about applying part
of your pipeline to the more naive
methods like these where you maybe like
substitute the in colder part with the
part yeah so no BAE fits the bill so in
a VA II conditional ones you can set up
a VA II you can set up one of these
factor models using a deep generative
model which is the model that the VA II
fits and then as for the second part of
the VA e which is the amortized
inference that is fair game as well so
you could use amortized inference
anywhere here as long as the resulting Z
hats capture the population distribution
of the assigned causes well again the KL
collapse that's a matter of whether or
not the inference procedure is working
or not that's separate so we're here
we're using whatever inference procedure
we're deciding to use of course if you
decide to fit a model where it doesn't
fit the data well and the Z hats don't
predict the held-out causes be it for
Cal collapse or another reason then it
won't work but you'll be able to detect
it yeah if there's a known confounder is
there a relatively straightforward way
to eliminate it before you do the
factorization so you don't bother
spending effort finding it that's a good
question so with known confounders you
can add them anywhere you want so you
can condition on them when you've when
you
Fitzie or you cannot condition on them
when you fitzy and only condition on
them when you fit the outcome right if
they are known single cause confounders
or other known confounders you know why
hope that Z is capturing them when I can
condition on it since I've measured it
that said that does lead to higher
variance so you know it because you're
fitting a higher dimensional model in
the outcome model but ya know so adding
no and confounders is is straightforward
I'm gonna think of a way to answer the
questions geographically okay and then
let me know if you are not in nearest if
you get a new question
yes so you talked about scalability but
I'm actually kind of interested in the
opposite direction where I can imagine
there are a lot of domains especially in
certain science fields where you might
measure our data might be very high
dimensional but you might be able to
take a couple thousand or even a couple
hundred measurements that moves do you
have a sense of how well this is able to
capture compounds in that situation
that's a good question so right well in
the in in the collage of simulations
there are some low data simulations
there like including with just two
causes and small data sets but there's
another that I want to make something
else that your question reminds me of
there are a lot of settings where you
know it might be difficult to obtain
data about X&Y but just data about X is
easy to obtain then you can use the data
about sorry a and Y but just data about
a is easy to obtain then you can use
these factor models to to with your
massive data set of say text to get
substitute confounders and for your
smaller data set of text and whatever
outcome it is you care about you can use
those substitute confounders which would
be well estimated because they were
estimated from the much larger data set
to to try to provide an answer to that
smaller more expensive causal inference
problem I'm going this way and then back
this way oh yeah sure
so I can't do it briefly but I can do it
okay so we wrote this paper we put it on
the archive and then Alex Dunmore wrote
a very nice paper which said that our
paper was impossible and so I want to
tell you and so that led us to then
refine our theorems a bit to make them
possible and although well let me
explain
so in causal inference if you're not
analyzing data you're worrying about
identifiability
and a causal quantity is identifiable if
it can be written as a function of the
observed variables in other words if I
observe an infinite amount of data
from my process can I identify some kind
of can I make a prediction under
intervention can I use the joint
distribution of the the observable joint
distribution to make a prediction about
some other joint distribution where I've
intervened
that's what identification is about now
Alex Dunmore wrote this very nice paper
where he gives two examples in the
multiple causal inference setting where
the expectation of why in the world
where I intervene on a is not
identifiable in other words if and the
two settings are one where all the
causes are binary and the outcome is
binary and the latent confounder is
binary and the other one is is the real
valued analog everything is real the
outcome is real and the latent
confounder is real and he's right so the
you know the expectation of Y given to a
is not identifiable meaning I can change
something about the way the world works
and the observation distribution stays
the same okay
these are nice results they help flesh
out the theory of multiple causal
inference but identification still as
possible so first of all in the movie
example identification is fine because
the causes were binary and the revenue
was continuous but moreover if you
assume that you can pinpoint a
substitute confounders ihab then you can
identify things like the contrast
between two interventions even in the
two settings that Alex d'amour
identifies points out and also you can
identify a subset of causes under
intervention okay with some other
assumptions but that's the sense in
which the theory is a little more
nuanced than I gave earlier other
questions yeah so it seems like we get a
distribution over Z at the first step
then you're admitting these fact of
olives by discard all the distribution
information and just go after an imputed
mean estimate see when I'm computing
these such income policy what am I
giving up and that's a good question so
the question was I'll repeat the
question it seems like we are we we get
a nice distribution over Z a posterior
distribution over Z and I'll just add to
your question it's a meaningful
posterior over Z because that's at the
individual level right there's only so
many actors that posterior is really
have some spread to it Rhett as opposed
to like a posterior condition on all the
data and so why did we then just use the
posterior expectation okay so the first
answer is for convenience it was a way
to construct an estimate of Z because
what we're getting you know there's two
distributions of Z at play there's the
posterior that you're mentioning but
then there's also the population
distribution of Z which is like the Z
hats across all the movies okay and
that's the Z that's the distribution of
Z that we really care about that's one
that we correct for when we do
downstream causal inference as to your
question we did it for convenience that
said if you look in the paper at that
collage or the simulations that make
that make up the collage you know we can
use that posterior to do a kind of
uncertainty estimation about the causal
effect in particular rather than use the
posterior mean you could just sample a Z
from the posterior and get a collection
of samples for each individual do causal
inference and get a causal effect now do
the same thing get a causal effect do
the same thing get a causal effect and
that gives you a distribution over the
causal effect and that lets you measure
the uncertainty of the causal effect it
also by the way helps you identify when
you're in one of these more models
that's not identified because then you
are going to get this improper
distribution as the causal effect so you
can almost identify when you are not
identified nothing here yeah so at the
beginning you mentioned that in the
classical approach it's not testable
whether you've gotten less efficient set
of compounders and correct wondering
here and maybe the answer to the
previous question was relevant is there
some kind of statistical test that you
can use to say when your predictive
check has been good enough that you can
have a certain level of confidence good
question so the question is all repeated
again is you know I said that
classically you you just hope that
you've thought of all the confounders
and that everything's okay but here is
there some kind of test and so write the
predictive check is is that is that test
here now the predictive check is in some
sense hearest
we have this predictive score that we
our threshold assay that the the
distribution is good enough we could
think about how to make that more
rigorous to be fair I don't think that's
totally our fault because the whole
world of Bayesian model diagnosis is
itself not that rigorous but working on
that is something that's on our list to
do for sure that said the predictive
check itself goes beyond just hope and
worry because at least there is a score
like I can see the mixture model failing
there for instance but ya know if the
predictive check passes and and you know
of course you have finite data and you
have this predictive check but if it
passes and it is capturing the
distribution well then you are safe you
have captured the this single the
unobserved multi cause confounders the
single cause confounders that's uncheck
able there you need to hope and worry or
measure confounders explicit connection
between the value of that predictive
score and differences correct yeah that
would be a problem to work on yeah and
and it's in again in the broader field
of how do I check a model so I know that
if I have my P of a the true
distribution of a and then I have my P
of a given by the marginal distribution
of a via the model I want to know that
those are equal yeah and then and this
is an interesting problem kind of a
Bayesian model diagnostics and checking
is part of the neglected landscape of
Bayesian meets frequentist methods which
is worth working on okay since I did a
geographically I feel like it's
unemployment go sure some short question
table
how that is done seen those well that
depends on the domain so you know like
in genomics I think it's probably fair I
don't know I don't know much about
genomics yeah
that wasn't sure if it was answered two
questions ago but I guess I was thinking
about it in the context of uh I don't
know if it's dumb question but
especially in the context of the
fairness question those is the answer Oh
could you say so given your Z a way to
sort of interpret what these parameters
are could you take sort of like a
testing approach so I measure something
that I suspect could be a confounder and
then check it against your list of
confounders somehow right so well first
of all the these the types of models
that we could fit like topic models and
Poisson factorization they're often very
interpretive or like if you looked at
these factors that you get out of the
Plus on factorization on movie casts you
see things like the superhero movies
come together right because they have
this big maybe that would be a better
picture for the youth of today they have
the same cast of character as Iron Man
and the others that said I also want to
emphasize that it doesn't matter now
that's kind of the point the point is
that I don't need to know what kind of
crazy confounder goes into choosing
movie casts because a line I need to
know is that I've captured the
population distribution of casts and
then I can answer the question I care
about which is how much is Robert De
Niro worth yeah shall we be concerned
this your own cost confounders to only
affect our company no that's a good
question and the answer is no we don't
need to worry about that so that is you
know that is just wrapped up in my model
of why that's adding just variance in my
model of Y now I could if if I think it
helps with estimating accurately the
outcome given the causes and the
substitute confounders sure I can
include it as frumps from like a bias
variance perspective but that doesn't we
don't need to worry about that in from
the perspective of biasing or causal
inferences with infinite data that can
be that can be ignored good question Oh
that's that's okay these to placate this
and then the effect um so if if I care
about a see what caused our very small
number of pauses but I want to get more
benefit out of your model can I add
extra causes things that I don't care
about things that maybe don't even
affect the outcome that I'm interested
in but might be associated some other
way
yeah limit of like the data I can dump
off yeah under the system of the trade
offs good question so of course you can
write so that these multi costs
confounders are inducing dependencies
among things that don't affect the
causes and there's really a deep
connection between this work and things
like proxy variables and no proxies and
if you look at we have a we have a
follow-up paper about the the structural
equation model approach to this which
which relates to those ideas but but the
answer is yes that you know those are no
proxies if you have other variables that
don't affect the outcome but are somehow
correlated with the causes those are
called no proxies of the confounder and
those do help yeah or they can't help I
guess subject to the bias-variance
issues as usual yeah thanks so much if
my decision to act in a movie depends on
whether you act in the movie because
either we get along or we don't get
along yeah make the factorization
Network we would like it that it so it
affects how much residual variance there
is and whether you and I are in the
movie for understanding how much we're
worth like if 99 percent of the time you
bring me along to the set to act then
there's only that kind of a little bit
of variance left to understand our
separate effects and so that's the issue
with that you could theoretically
capture it with a Z right you'd capture
that dependence but it would leave
little power for estimating the causal
effect that said something we're working
on now our latent mediators the idea
that maybe you're terrible and I'm
terrible but when we're in the movie
together like it's magic
then late and mediator could capture
that Thanks
[Applause]